I don't think that you know a
Palestinian and Israeli would meet each
other on the street or in a bar it's so
important to me to constantly be
listening and connecting with people who
have a different stake in this game from
the other side sitting in the presence
of everyone you kind of get to feel more
of what they're feeling and I think that
it's what we all need right now to
humanize the so frequently dehumanized
obviously there's two sides to this
discussion and the only way out is
[Music]
through I have lost someone in the
war first of all I consider everyone in
um in razza or Palestine to be an
extended member of my family but I
actually lost 23 extended members of of
my family
inaz yeah um and for me uh in the West
Bank where my family lives uh I lost one
of my cousins who was uh simply coming
home from work at our family grocery
store and uh just happened to be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and ended
up getting shot by an Israeli soldier
that was posted up on the corner looking
for someone and shot him and uh he
immediately died sorry I'm so sorry two
friends who um got killed at a massacre
actually one of them um her uh burnt
body just was recognized few days ago uh
40 something days after um
and they actually bury a little part of
the leg that was the only thing that was
left but I have a list of uh tens of uh
friends who um got killed cuz it's it's
a long War I guess it's it's I didn't
start on October 7th from my point of
view I guess um and uh yeah sorry for
your loss yeah um I lost friends at no
the one of the nature parties that was
attacked it's actually another nature
party that was also attacked called
Psyduck which not a lot of people really
know about a smaller party smaller party
yeah I was there um yeah I mean Nova was
the same location of my first nature
party in 2012 I've been going to them
since then and to say the community was
devastated is really an understatement
um yeah it was just horrible it's really
what it
was sorry for you I lost it I lost a lot
of friends that day on October 7th uh
one of them was my best friend one of my
best friends her name was Mo she was
with us at the beach that day um and she
went home to her mother and on the way
home hundreds of terrorists caught her
and shot her
dead two friends of mine that was in on
the Nova Super Nova Music Festival also
died there and they were murdered right
on the spot and they found their body
just dumped somewhere inside Gaza two
weeks
after and one of my best friends big
brother called uh been called that day
by the Army to help uh the people of U
the village of
bay uh which got taken by Hamas
terrorists and when he went there with
his unit he died there um living uh
behind a wife
that they married maybe one year
ago
and my mom best
friend I have a daughter that was
married to to a guy named Tai he was
also in the Army and on the second day
he went to zakim where I was at the
beach and he also died there along with
his two best
friends
and since October 7 I lost too many
people and just keep just keep
counting yeah I think we all can agree
that we've all been doing that since
October 7th you know I have a lot of
friends where I live in Washington DC
who have their direct family members in
Gazza right now you know they left for
studying or
jobs and every day having to hear them
frantically try to call to see if their
families are alive you know one of them
his brother was one of the last standing
nurses at alifa hospital up until just
last week he finally left the
uncertainty when it's like your
immediate family I think
it's
debilitating and you know it puts you
into a tunnel where you only can see
your grief but it's obvious that the
grief is everywhere and we're all
feeling the same things and you know
none of it should have happened and none
of it should be
happening um which is why I think a
conversation like this right now is
extremely important so that we can all
understand that and and to your point
when you see it happening to your family
um I'm sure friends probably a similar
feeling
um it settles at a much deeper level um
when I we have a family group chat um a
lot of my relatives are are my aunts are
in
Egypt so we have a family group chat and
when events transpired and you start
seeing the group chat transform from
checking in on each other in the regular
you know memes and banter uh have you
guys checked in have you heard from them
oh we haven't heard in three days
electricity has been out when I started
seeing that on my WhatsApp group it it
um like I said I consider everyone in
Palestine
and any innocent humans really to be
part of our extended family but um that
just resonates at a much deeper level
I've been sitting with a lot of guilt uh
being the only you know American
Palestinian of my cousins you know my
family made it out my dad wanted you
know to give us a better life and so you
know he brought us he brought my mom
here I was born and raised here but when
I was a teenager we we moved back and I
lived in Palestine so it was a shock to
see how the occupation affected our
daily lives you know and I was I was 13
you know but coming from Ohio from like
the Midwest you know everything is open
and free and then here you are like
going to the grocery store and there's
tanks rolling down the street you know
Soldiers with guns walking around then
some days like we couldn't go to school
cuz they would close the checkpoints and
close the border like you're not going
today and you know as a child I thought
that was kind of cool like oh I don't
have to go to school today but I look
back now and I'm like that's kind of
messed up how long ago did you move out
like did you guys move out from from
Palestine it was in the '90s the mid90s
I grew up in southeast Jerusalem and um
I
remember um actually in beginning of the
9s we used to go to uh kilia and Janine
and we used to do shopping over there
cuz uh it was cheaper you know and we
used to uh eat Kus over there and uh
good humas uh a lot bro a lot my
favorite knf you know so I um I actually
even um understand some of the language
I I grew up in a place with uh um a lot
of um uh Israeli Muslims and um and
you're right it was it I remember
actually it was it was a great time in
the '90s in that in that area when uh
when everything got more complicated uh
into the second intifa when when I
started um my military time I was F and
a half years in the military I was
special Ground Forces I know Gaza like I
know my uh my uh hand and um the
problems are of of closing check post
and everything it started only in the
end of the 90s I'm talking about
dramatically because of a lot of
terrorist attack that happened in uh in
Israel so so in the beginning of the the
intifa uh on in
2000 um um it was impossible for Jewish
people obviously to get into janin or or
uh uh obviously the entire West Bank uh
but before that we could we could
because before that we didn't have that
many terrorist attack so the occupation
from from from the way we see it
occupation I don't call it occupation I
call it uh uh protect your country from
uh some terrorist organization extremist
I think you called it right I am I will
be the last person that will say it's a
it's a whole group because I have a lot
of some friends up until today even from
back in the days and even childhood
childhood friends that I grew up with so
I I'm uh my my past is very rich with
the Muslim um uh Arabs Israeli Arabs uh
culture but um in my opinion is is super
strong cuz I felt the different between
the '90s
and the terrorist attack that uh
happened because of uh um uh the Hamas
obviously they they woke up the monster
let's put it that
way okay so I didn't step up because
while my mom and dad know people who
have been victims I had the privilege of
being born and raised in Detroit and
spending two three months at a time on
multiple occasions in the West Bank so
that's that's why I didn't step up what
was your name tal tal what what you said
when you first steep down that you know
everyone there is your family I feel
that way as a Jew about Isel but I
didn't want to take away from who I'm
sure had real personal connections but
we we feel it deeply everything that we
see and and of course I know many people
who live in Israel who thank God were
not in the south on October 7th and who
are okay right now thank God but we're
checking in and everybody knows somebody
it's like we're all one degree away from
tragedy um so that mean that's why I
disagreed I didn't lose anyone but I did
get married in Palestine I'm not going
to to say which Village to protect my
ex-husband um but before we got married
he was arrested his village was um
attacked by the IDF and he threw a
rock this big at an Israeli tank and was
arrested for four years where he was
beaten tortured uh starved um and
according to his family I didn't know
him at the time um he never came out the
same and even after we got married you
know asking him the questions and you
know what happened and how was it in
jail and you could see the fear in his
eyes and you could just feel his pain
and a lot of people don't realize that a
lot of Palestinians that get arrested
are never put on a fair trial that's
actually notal what you're saying here H
it's not all two-thirds of Palestinians
are not put on trial they're not charged
H yeah
yeah told you what happened to
my they always went always is she lying
I'm giving you a personal account of
what happened to my husband um this
isn't a source or a website or a video I
yeah I think that's a personal story I
think basically what he's saying is that
according to our law which maybe is not
necessarily always upheld that according
to our law and if it was to be
discovered there would Pro there'd be
Mass protests like we don't with that as
a people and the law legally states that
they would have to be a tri you don't
not everybody's like that in Israel to
be fair that's fair so what about the
children that are imprisoned do they go
through due trial a 12-year-old a
13-year-old a
14-year-old is there any is there is
there any trial that justifies children
to be I'm giving you I'm telling you
right now that my husband did not get a
my ex-husband did not get a fair trial
why because it was years you you took
his situation and and I'm not taking
away from your situ situation like you
did with mine you took our personal
experience and
situation and with all due respect made
it about you when an Israeli tank
attacks a Palestinian Village are all
Palestinians supposed to lay there and
just take it so we know the prisons are
filled with children they're terrorists
too they're murderers if you throw a
rock if you throw a rock you a terrorist
yeah oh if you throw a rock you're ter
if you attack us if you attack with this
is called this is the prime example of
not having due trial a trial means you
get investigate you look at the cause of
what happened you look at the
because this is the just this is the
logic this is the logic of isra if
you're Palestinian you're i' love to say
some final words about the actual prompt
if that's okay because I think it's
disrespectful to all the people that we
did lose during this war to go down this
route right now I actually broke the
news on the nature party before any
other media outlet from friends that
were there um and I'm sitting there
getting these messages at night time was
Saturday night and it was horrific and I
think that what we're all experiencing
in terms of checking in on our family I
mean my sister just gave birth in a bomb
shelter like a week ago you know I think
that's a really common experience and
it's something that both people from
both sides can relate to and it's one of
the areas that a lot of these random
people who are so disassociated from
this that are chiming in can't actually
feel and I think it's just a really
intense thing and I know that for myself
personally I can't log on to Facebook
anymore without just seeing funeral and
Shiva announcements and I find that to
be very hard to go through every day but
I have to check because we don't even
know who's missing or who's dead 100%
just yet so like last week my friends
two twin cousins that were 12 were found
finally identified their bodies were
burnt to such a crisp that it took that
long so I just think like with a prompt
like this we need to give due respect to
the people that we all lost and just
take a moment to just validate the fact
that so many of us are sitting here
having lost family members friends
people we've met throughout the years
friends of friends cousins of cousins
ants I mean it's almost impossible to be
Untouched by this um so yeah I'm just
sorry for everyone's losses and may
everybody's memory be a blessing
inshallah and we apologize for your loss
as well I would like to point out even
though it is very difficult that your
sister gave birth at a bomb shelter
there are no bomb shelters for the
people of
Kaza I Rely more on the information I
get from social media than the
news uh obviously it's very important
that we're using like verified news
sources there's so much misinformation I
think from both sides um I know that
I've corrected people on the Palestinian
side like hey I don't think that this is
actually true like maybe you know we
need a source if you're reposting
something from someone else also tag
whichever you know journalist or news
site it's coming from just to streamline
information because you know
misinformation can hurt the cause more
than the actual information not being
shared truly and I think in order to
honor what is happening and to be able
to truly Advocate it's important that
we're only putting forth the truth
there's so many different kinds of
networks ones that are more on the
ground like a jaaz and mayadin and then
obviously you have the American Media
CNN and New York Post and New York you
know times and Washington Post I feel
like a lot of times in general I feel
like American Media mainstream media has
not been Fair on so many other issues
previous to this and so I don't only
necessarily go to them but I do look at
all sources of media because I want to
get a fair view of what's happening and
I also look at Israeli media can I ask a
question because I saw you both like in
your opinion is the American media bias
anti- Palestinian or anti-jewish bias is
what you see when you say that the
American media is not anti anti
Palestinian that's so interesting cuz
for the Jews we think it's so
anti-jewish bias they can't be both
right it's one or the other and anti-
Palestinian oh cuz you said it is
because like if you look at the wording
there selective language there's
omission and there's adding of certain
words that paint a narrative very
strongly so when they say clashes
between um you know Palestinian uh
Israeli forces and Hamas but you look at
what the actual story is and you read
the fine print which most people
unfortunately don't do um it turns out
that Israeli forces in that whatever
situation might have stormed into a
village and shot a child but the
headline reads clashes anytime it's the
other way around terrorist so um I think
that's it's very important to label
people correctly and some people are
terrorist and they should be labeled as
such but when you omit certain
information for a specific purpose this
is what the Western media what I love
about this is what literally what you're
saying could be taken verbatim from like
a Jewish dinner conversation they do the
exact same thing to the Jews where
absolutely where like the day after this
October 7th Massacre the guys flying in
and like raping and burning people are
being called militants and not
terrorists freedom freedom fighters
there's like literally examples of for
example if there's a terrorist attack in
Israel the BBC will publish like IDF uh
you know shoots Palestinians as opposed
to like the terrorists literally came
and tried to stab people and then got
neutralized by the IDF and so I think
like the language honestly and by the
way I have a lot of Palestinian friends
I know you guys think the media is
biased against you and I know we also
think that too I see this on both of my
feeds it's like so blatant how we both
feel this way and I think that instead
of dismissing the fact that like we just
don't see that maybe we need to send
each other examples of articles that we
feel are completely biased and have
really crappy headlines and the truth is
by the way most these media orgs don't
even have a personal incentive in the
region they're just shering and stirring
this pot for no like and we're just
fighting over this we shouldn't let them
do that but the BBC is legitimately so
anti-semitic CNN has taken years before
they turned around
and their headlines are an absolute
atrocity they never report on anything
that happens for the Israeli side they
only report on our response but how is
that anti-semitic because they never
report on the attacks that come towards
us they only report on what we do and
yes all I see it's well it's it's it's
interesting
how we have I I would say that we're
probably looking at things through
different lenses So when you say the
news you see something on social media
you should definitely verify as far as
the US media and this is just my opinion
the US media that we've been fed has
been feeding into lies in over the years
not just this conflict in general So
when you say they don't have a a let's
say a dog in the race it's just not true
because Joe Biden clearly supports
Israel unequivocally so you can't say
that there is no Israeli bias in America
the US always stands with Israel that's
a fact I have a problem with Joe Biden
probably like everybody does okay Jo bid
not
think according to you no because the
Democrats definitely Biden repeated the
unsubstantiated claim that 40 babies
were Joe Biden say that because he saw
what we showed him if I believe Joe
Biden and his support to Israel I think
it's a big BS yeah you think so Jo Biden
or Israel he just fed Iran I don't think
just you know lit came on I think it's a
political um America doesn't support
Israel well I don't think well America
it's not Jo we just wasted 15 billion of
America America
not back to the news thing though the
IDF has an extensive history of lying
they lied about killing sharen abak the
journalist who my mom was friends with I
was going to walk up here but she wasn't
my friend she was my mom's friend um
they said that something else happened
to her independent investigations came
to believe a sniper while she was
wearing in in Janine I believe it was
she was wearing a news report jacket
they murder her that's just one example
so the News lies all the time that's a
good example of how they didn't label
that corre when it first came they
didn't la a Palestinian reporter dies no
no she wasn't died she was killed by a
sniper intentionally shot between the
helmet look look at the the rocket the
rocket that fell in the parking lot of
alifa Hospital how that was that was a
catastrophe but no I I agree that
they're probably missing on both of us
the same
goes so do you remember the the whole
big thing about the alifa being bombed
by Israel that hundreds of people had
that the news came out
in minutes after minutes sorry hospital
after 2 minutes they said 500 people and
this Israel had bombed every major news
island reported this that's what
happened no no it was proven very
unequivocally that's not what happened
it was a a a Islamic Jihad rocket failed
went off so our rets are that strong it
fell that's why not 500 people didn't
die it would have been a much larger
damage if it had been uh a dropped bomb
from an Israeli plane like they said it
was but it was 500 people died is not
that much damage people didn't die from
that but 20,000 overall have you know
that's not what we're talking about but
I am I am talking about that I want to
talk about where did you get that number
but 10 to 50 that's that's what the
numbers is that were that were reported
once all of the death settled from all
the other International organizations to
bring it back to news to see like the
way that some news organizations verify
or post later or post earlier but spell
things wrong or things like that it's
kind of telling to see how quickly
misinformation can spread I will say
social media can't just be completely
dismissed because it does present sort
of a firsthand perspective however I
prefer to get my firsthand perspective
from my friends and my family on the
ground and I think that that's the news
that if anything I was kind of more
hoping to hear from today about because
I feel like that's the personal
experiences that we're not actually
getting to hear from each other online
um or on the news and I think that
that's kind of the firsthand news that
people should be sharing um you know me
personally like I get the rocket alarm
app on my phone but I also get a text
from like eight different what'sapp
group chats you know when rocks is
everybody okay is everybody okay did it
so I think that that's also a really
important news source and I would
ideally love to be able to share
firsthand news like that with people
like you and also receive it from you as
well I think that that's the most
reliable info we can get yeah I mean
like I said I have a lot of friends who
have family directly there so they do
get you know photos and videos when
there's internet access you know but I
was sitting with one of my friends one
day when he called me hysterical at 7 a.
and told me his parents had just called
him and told him to say his goodbyes to
them
because the bombs were getting closer to
their
house and the fear in his voice
really
like suffocated me and I didn't know
what to do for him so he came over we
tried calling his family
his parents weren't picking up I didn't
know what to do for him you know
like he's like my parents are going to
die I'm in America and I can't be there
for
them and I had never seen or been in a
situation where I've had someone so
close to me dealing with something like
that I mean he literally stayed by my
side the entire day until we were able
to um verify that his family was going
to be okay and that they finally moved
away from their neighborhood and so
they're still safe to this day but you
know seeing videos directly from friends
like you said like on the ground just
has another layer of
Devastation uh because it makes you
realize these are like real people that
are connected to the suffering a lot of
times because news agencies can't really
be on the ground in in certain hot areas
like that it's good to have people that
are reliable that you can connect with
and get that information from um and it
brings an extra layer I think of just um
Humanity because it's not just some like
Corporation that's you know reporting on
the news it's someone real that's like
there in the midst of it you know we
need that we need that because a lot of
our casualties are not reported on in
fact this morning I was
in the bathroom on my phone as we do and
and I I looked up children killed I was
trying to find a specific child and the
there was four that came up two of them
sorry five total two of them again from
like several hours ago right and then
there was four others that died three
days ago in Janine right six a 16y old a
15y old a 14y old and a 19y old right
and there was it was so difficult to
find there was Zero Western sources
reporting on this I had to search it in
Arabic for their names to come up in the
Palestinian casualty role and it was
almost impossible I was shocked that
there was four below 18 one of them 19
miners that died and I could not find
this reporting I'm like wait I'll Google
it oh it'll come up oh here and it just
wouldn't come up it's like H so yeah we
need to have people on the ground
the the the the others like him that are
reporting because there is a bias
against us and our stories are being
hidden they are being erased all I'm
trying to get you to see is that it's
it's the same on both sides but it can't
be the exact same feel it can't it's
either it's either one side stories are
buried and the others disagree I think
both sides can be buried clearly they
are cuz I'm not trying to invalidate
your experience but you're trying to
validate mine I'm telling you we
different exact sure let's say it's from
the media
overall from exactly from what we
suffering it feels to me like we're in a
movie and we are the actors and we are
the puppets and there is some some
people out there they watching the movie
and just enjoy and eating their fruits
and there is a lot of uh uh uh people
suffering in this listen I'm listening
to you I swear I want to cry I swear no
one no one in this world and I don't
care what size if it's a Palestinian or
Jewish or or Ukrainian or Russian
supposed to live under boms no freaking
way agree and I'm talking to you as a
veteran as a someone who was there
inside is someone who volunteered to
carry all those is someone who has a
friends Muslims no one and and you know
what all of my friends also in Israel no
one wants to go into Gaza we know we are
afraid it's it's it's it's afraid the
out of us to go into Gaza we didn't
want to as friends as as kids I went
when I was 19 years old we don't want to
go there absolutely we don't want to but
that's sad we don't want to it's super
sad bro it's super sad what I'm trying
to say is that listen you're talking
about the publication we are talking
also about the
publication we have the same problem we
are suffering from the same and some
people out there watching and it's like
and we are puppets and we play we we
play the game of our game you play the
game of your game and we are like there
is there is some scash here and some
people are benefit from this now look
our government the news uh uh Outlets or
social media what's the difference
everyone has an agenda we can agree that
Al jazer definitely has more of a
sympathy and a bias towards the
Palestinian struggle just like we can
agree Western countries and media
Outlets have unequivocally always
supported Israel now now it's a little
less bias now it's a little less bias
yes they have yes they have some do
perhaps but can the entire every media
Outlet in all of America is you ever
heard we're talking about the major on
CNN
Fox oh because they're being more honest
now that hates you they've always hated
because they're showing the children D
in
Gaza that's how we is it a fact that us
sends money to Israel yes the media also
us but us also sends money to Palestine
they also just released a ton of money
to Iran the US is the biggest podster in
this whole thing theim
I mean it's like they love to cause
trouble in the
region
of
America Israel Palestine conflict
brought to you by Qatar Iran us Russia
everybody that has no actual direct
interest and just wants to mess with us
that's the issue and and it's like he
said we are sitting here like puppets
while our all of our governments still
play us but this however this is what I
do have a problem with and you can agree
disagree every time and again with all
due respect right we're trying to find
Middle Ground here but hear me out
before we all go ra okay for 75 years of
illegal occupation we have been bleeding
and we have been suffering whether you
want to hear it or not please respect
that that's what we're saying I I get it
I understand if I maybe if I was sitting
on your side okay but just have some I'm
asking for compassion where is the
humanity and every time every time we
say well this Palestinian person was
unived by Israeli forces or this this
and that it's no offense then on the
Israeli side yeah but what about us okay
10,000 Palestinians just were unived and
bombed in Gaza then the Israelis what
about us we have been bleeding and
crying for 75 years when is it our turn
to mourn you're right in terms of bias
of the media Western media against
Palestinians have you ever heard a
western publication states that
Palestine has the right to defend itself
follow-up question do any of you believe
that Palestine has a right to defend
itself the first question is actually
really interesting I haven't I I that's
actually a really interesting question
is that indicative of a bias uh no
because I'd like to answer the second
question I'd like to answer that I think
that there's a bias against both of us
by the way I don't disagree no no no no
the news I think news is biased towards
both of us and I think we're coming to
an understanding of that however I think
the second question is also very
interesting because the way that we see
it we are never on the offensive the way
that I get that I get that you guys
disagree just hear me out cu I think
this is where there's a huge
misunderstanding okay from Israel's
perspective we've offered peace so many
different times from our perspective we
have diplomatically offered peace so
many times and it's always responded to
with war and violence and so from our
perspective we would never initiate
those Wars or violences had they not
been initiated towards us that's why we
call ourselves the IDF Israeli Defense
Forces so for us that's our perspective
and right now unequivocally if there
were no no terrorist attacks so much of
what is happening just simply would not
exist everything that's been in place
the blockades the this the that and the
other they all came after as responses
so when we disengage from Gaza in ' 05
we did not have the blockades that
existed we did not have the blockades
that existed now why did those happen
because in the following years right
after that Rockets immediately started
flying from Gaza Terror attacks
immediately started coming out so for us
we have done from our perspective right
from our perspective this is how we view
it we are constantly offering diplomatic
concessions that are turned down and
turned down with violence and often with
violence on some of our holiest days so
from your perspective defending yourself
I feel very bad that this is the
difference in perception because I can
understand where you're coming from in
feeling frustrated that that that the
use defense is not used in your uh for
you guys for your side and so I can
understand how that would be very
frustrating but from our perspective
this is where we're coming from our
children should not inherit this
conflict
I'm glad that everybody stepped forward
um because I think it's important that
you at the at the very like you know
Foundation of what we're doing here
today that we all agree
that this isn't a way to live and uh we
can't keep suffering you know more
heartbreak and more
losses um you know I always used to say
like you know my parents used to tell me
that when they had children that they
had hoped you know Palestine would be
free and we would be able to go back and
live a life with without any hardship
and you know now I have people my age
you know who have children my sisters
and you know a lot of family members who
have kids themselves and you know having
to have that conversation and talk about
who we are as a people and our history
and what we've been through and you know
passing on that intergenerational trauma
you know that continues to be carried
you know from our great grandparents all
the way down to us it it's it's
heartbreaking and it this isn't a world
that we should
be allowing something like this to
perpetuate yeah it would be great for
everybody to be able to go and to live
and to yeah walk the beaches and visit
the holy sites and not have to fear for
their life while doing it this is like
who wants to live like this forever this
is crazy if I'm going to bring kids into
this world enough is enough and I don't
want to live in a world without the
optimism that peace is a possibility I
really don't I think that that's like a
world to live in I refuse to believe
that as a younger generation as a newer
smarter more uh informed generation that
we can't come together and make
something tangible actually happen for
our kids and I totally agree and I think
the only way to do that is for for
people on both sides to recognize each
other and that I agree we're we're going
to disagree on whatever but like one
side has their story their truth their
lived experience the other has the same
we don't have to convince the other to
see it the exact same way we just have
to see each other and and acknowledge
that we're both in this situation we
both want to get out of it and let's
treat each other like human beings and
find the way out of it Jonah what's your
involvement in this what do you mean
what's your involvement in this conflict
that we were speaking about I'm a Jew oh
so can like what where are you from like
where where do you live I live in Los
Angeles where were you born Los Angeles
okay it's easy for you to say what you
said even though I agree with what you
said that we do need to be able to see
ey eye we do need to be able to find a
future for our children but respectfully
you were born in Los Angeles you were
raised in Los
Angeles the one of the best places in
the world I love it right yeah you don't
have the answer to this conflict to this
occupation so do the people from Jord
Jonah's thoughts on this conflict are
not invalid just because he was born in
La I think that's crazy to sort of
invalidate I said I agree with his
sentiment he still from Los Angeles but
you're still deqing him to a degree by
saying he's born in La respectfully I
just don't think that's right I think
that he has a lot of skin in the game
family in Israel he was just there with
getting attacks all over I think
actually there is a big room for people
that that comes from different countries
and they feel hurt from from some reason
from from social media or whatever and
come and say what they think about the
situation the problem is there's not
going to be I don't believe that this is
going to end as long as Palestinians are
oppressed put into blockades in Gaza put
into all these different things that
they don't have freedom I've gone there
I've I've lived there for months at a
time four different occasions I had to I
went to Jerusalem my cousin couldn't
come with me these type of things are
not going to ensure peace what's going
to a rating of of ala or or uh going to
Janine and Refugee all these things so
of course of course of course these are
come on these are val my
friend the point what I'm saying I I'll
respond him let him finish IDE is not
ace it's a bource I think we have
disagreements on what we think needs to
happen to end you think oh well
everybody just everybody disarm on the
Palestinians side and submit I think
that they're not what I said did anybody
hear me say that he just pointed at me
and said that that's what I said who
said that he said it who said that okay
well then I apologize for that but I
think I think that the solution would be
um to end end the occupation the isra
OCC and I totally hear that but of as I
said there's both two sides to every
story so the Israeli side would be well
they need to stop having terrorist
attacks in Israel and we can stop at
this you that's why I'm saying we can go
back and forth a lot of things need to
happen from a lot of parties it's going
to require a lot of outside parties
having influence from the Arab region
and the us bringing people to the table
making things happen if we if we're just
stuck in the int fighting of I'm there
I'm there we're hating each other that's
that's what never going to and the
occupation is absolutely the problem so
even though you said this is how I think
it'll be resolved it needs to be the
other countries and people need to come
together I'm saying that the root of the
problem is the oppression and it's the
the land theft Conant settlement from
your side yeah well that's most people
in the world think that but is there
objective truth I would love to respond
to what you're saying there's also
objective truth to both sides
objective truth doesn't have two sides
objective truth is true is there that's
what my question was is there objective
truth are you married I would no there's
objective truth to both sides I promise
you that's actually hilarious is but
that I would I would love to answer you
because I actually think that this is a
really important respond yeah I didn't
ask a question sorry I would like to
respond to you apologize for using the
word answer I would love to speak to you
just openly cuz I think what you said is
really important and it's something that
I've thought of for many years there's a
really good book called catch 67 by Ma
Goodman both the right and the left
hated equally so you know it's pretty
decent and it talks about the idea that
we can't look at everything from a
non-binary perspective so we can't look
at it as peace or no peace because
you're right tensions need to be limited
relations need to grow we can't just
like immediately offer something and
then boom it's accepted then boom we've
been trying that for the last however
many years and it hasn't worked so I
agree that we do need to minimize the uh
the we need to improve sorry the
day-to-day lives of both Israelis and
Palestinians uh travel within the
Westbank is a huge issue and catch 67
talks about that and potentially
building a road that's Palestinian
controled through all of the cities to
be able to improve Travel and Transport
so there aren't these sort of weird
blockades or blockages that where you
can't bring your friend to somewhere or
you can't visit a cousin who's in a
different town there's actually a lot of
really awesome orgs that are working on
these sort of tangible actionable items
that we can do to improve the situation
and the lives on the ground and if
anything I think in the last like four
or five years what we've seen with the
Abraham Accords bringing peace between
So Many Nations and Israel in the Arab
countries to me as a Moroccan Jew I
almost cried at the thought of peace
between my countries it's like
reconciling my two identities excuse me
let me please finish reconciling my two
identities to me was so special and so
that to me was one of the things that
we've done uh bringing in you know many
people from Gaza with work visas into
Israel to people to work in
is yeah but no but I'm talking since
then I'm talking since then the last
four years and if you've noticed in the
last 11 months in Israel we've had
number of protests to be able to also
further improve the situations we are
working towards that I think it's one of
the most important things is for for us
to not look at it as a non-binary thing
progressives are so quick to look at
sexuality and gender non-binary but when
it comes to these sort of complex issues
everything is Black or White it's peace
or no peace that's never going to happen
we need to come together and work on
tangible things we can do to improve the
situation so you're right I actually
really agree with you and I wish that
you could hear my agreeance so all I was
going to reply to was the Abraham
Accords the Palestinians were not even
involved in that so no we don't accept
the Abraham Accords cuz we weren't even
confronted about it that's what I think
most people you ask on the Palestine
side would say and this is a history
that goes back A Century of this
Palestinians being excluded when the
neba first started a million
Palestinians nearly a million 750 plus
Palestinians were expelled from their
homes some fled others wor murdered
right and then you have the 1947
partition plan which is like hey we just
got here we're taking 55% you guys are
keeping 45 you're saying we've offered
many resolutions who would do that if
somebody came to America right now and
took our country and said hey you guys
get 45% nobody would accept that so you
got to also look at it from that
perspective so so
um I have
kids uh when we were in um in Tel Aviv
and on October 7 I was in Tel Aviv and
then we drove down to Jerusalem um we
heard the alarm goes off I'm like do you
hear that do you hear that I'm like and
my son goes yeah what's that I'm like
that's the alarm I'm like and then I'm
like my kids doesn't even know what is
it so to the point I'm happy my kid
didn't know what is it cuz I know what
is it I grew up into this conflict in my
house we don't talk about that we don't
talk what's like my my my my son I I was
we start to tell them about the story
about the war there is terrorist my son
was like that in in Hebrew what's the
Hest my kids doesn't know anything about
this because because for me I
don't they don't they don't they don't
supposed to know about that my question
is why the kids in Gaza are learning
books of Hitler's books of Hitler you
see books of Hitler all over all over
the schools all over shifa all over the
schools they're all over all those books
that goes both
ways there is no there is no even one
program in any any school any school in
Israel that teach you to hate Arabs not
even one book not even one stories in
school in school curriculum very likely
that was planted that's very likely that
was planted but can I if are you done
planted come on by by by by soldiers
like me 20 years old soers planted those
things M can I answer your question with
another question it's if you have more
to say go ahead no no it's it's because
every time we will say something it's
been planted you guys are lying listen I
was a soldier 20 years old you know when
you go into Gaza by the way when you are
20 until you get into the house you want
to kill yourself you don't want to beat
her you don't want to beat her as a
soldier you don't want to beater so
there is no soldiers who planting books
to take a
photoal leadership also by um human
watch organization there was an
investigation that in Israeli schools
inside of Israel not all of them but
some of them that they were taught to
hate
Palestinians
human you know how many Human Rights
Watch on their website that was an
investigation but I would like to go
back to the prompt if that's okay
everybody the reason why I don't want
any your kids or our kids to inherit
this this this conflict is because
number one maybe not for you guys but
for us as Palestinians we already risk
sitting on this panel not being able to
ever go back and visit our family in
Palestine ever again I do have family in
the West Bank I don't know if I said
that earlier my father's Palestinian and
my grandmother and great-grandmother are
actually Jewish uh from Germany um I
wanted to make sure everyone knew that
by I've I've been on Canary Mission
since 2014 because I'm an activist
however being on this panel or even
what's been happening the past month and
a half or two months whatever we're at
God help us all I risk of not being ever
to ever go back and visit any of my
family in West Bank again even though
I'm not saying kill this person kill
that you get where you get what I'm
saying just by saying free Palestine
they can stop me at the the Tel Aviv
airport and say that's it you can't come
in cuz you you have a cofia and you're
Palestinian and you said this on social
media and if I have kids one day maybe
my kids because I spoke up for Humanity
okay and again this is what this is on
whatever side you're talking about maybe
my kids won't be able to go back because
they're like well their mom her mom is
Rema she can't go back you know what I'm
saying this needs to end I am tired
I'm tired of talking about it I'm tired
of getting angry I'm sure you're tired
you're tired you're tired you're tired
we're I'm fed up with it you know when
people say oh Palestine never existed
Palestinians don't exist to take away
our right to exist is a problem for me
and that is a big and I tell people that
when they come on my Tik Tok live I stop
stop them right away for you to say that
Palestinians don't exist you are part of
the problem right there we do exist my
father does exist our voices matter our
Our Land matters we we we have been
there it's got to stop for everybody I
actually tweeted um Israel doesn't exist
Palestine doesn't exist I can't think of
two worse conversation starters because
I just think it's a ridiculous place to
start and in 1985 the Arab League
recognized Palestine and I think that we
should as well and so for me thank you
for saying yeah and so for me I think
that we have to start from humanization
like Jonah was saying earlier we can't
dehumanize each other otherwise we have
just no chance absolutely no chance
totally I think um in my surroundings
they they they accept the the the
existence obviously of uh uh pales
Palestine and and they accept exactly
what you just say right now they do they
do and actually maybe 99% of the people
I know right same the question is what's
the majority of your
surrounding saying about Jewish because
all we see right now all we feel by the
way we we feel what you feel by the way
and I'm not going to take it away from
you right whatever you feel right now I
swear I want to hug you I'm not going to
take it away from you but what we feel
is that Palestinian wants to make sure
that Jewish people has no right to live
in Israel and they need to die we can't
speak for everyone just like you can't
speak for all of your people I'm telling
you as a Palestinian I not because my
grandmother's Jewish we are not against
Jews we don't want to get rid of the
Jewish people and I love to hear that
and and and I swear to God I think I
think I agree 100% I would hear if I
would hear if I will hear to we don't
want Jewish to be to get killed because
they're Jewish people I swear it's open
everything to a conversation because all
I want is just to make sure that if you
guys sit in front of me you don't want
to kill me oh I'm down for everything
bro I'm down for
everything we do not want Jewish people
to die absolutely I don't think there's
a single Muslim that believes in Islam
truly that can in his right mind justify
in any way theologically rationally
logically that a Jewish person doesn't
have the right to live zero there's a
difference between being opposed to the
Zionist regime and the Zionist
governmental political policies and
being opposed to an individual who
subscribes who has nothing to do with
that part of the world who has a
religion of Judaism we're brothers we're
cousins Abraham had two sons is and is
right and we descend from them so we're
not only cousins we're half Brothers we
have a problem with the ideology whose
entire basis is establishing a state
strictly for Jewish people which makes
it by definition an apartheid state on
the land of another people so you don't
you don't acknowledge Israel as a
country this is one my question actually
the way it's currently defined
absolutely not I acknowledge you as a
human being absolutely do I acknowledge
so they should all
just that's I said the way that the
state is currently formed the ideologies
LED that led to its forming the land
without a people for a people without a
land the entire pretext to the formation
of the state we disagree with but can we
find the way find a different way to
ex find a different way to exist but not
with the idea that it's a majority
Jewish State Palestine I'm sorry it was
never meant to be a majority Jewish
State the intention of hold on listen 45
45%
majority 45% of the original proposed
Zionist state by Herzel was 45% was
meant to be Muslim Arab okay and there
was going to be a fractional percent 1%
Jewish in the Palestinian State okay so
we were willing to accept up to 45% of
our country being Arab be disappointed
with what's happening right now but hold
on a second the original premise the
original premise of Zionism is not to be
something to eradicate if anything it
says that we want to come in there with
diplomatic to be able to get the state
diplomatically to be able to not do it
through colonizers that's literally what
his letter States and I think it's
really important to understand that for
us Zionism is not some evil thing and
people have co-opted our term and use it
as a slur against us when to us it's
something sacred it means our right to
self-determination back in the land of
Israel just as you want the right to
self-determination for Palestinians back
in Palestine we also feel that same way
about Israel we and most of other people
think that Zionism is one way you think
it's that way right but what I want to
clarify okay so this where I'm going to
meet you halfway when when you said so
you want uh all Jews to F offer you
whatever you okay no no it's okay um
Zionism to us and the other people the
way that we know it as it is whatever
you think is what okay half the real way
manifested yes I want you I know but
this where we're going to meet halfway I
want you to know that at no point does
any person that's speaking up for
Palestine or is Palestinian or whatever
the case may be we we've never are there
radical people on each side yes there
are but we want to live in peace we want
to live as neighbors we want to love
each other it does not mean to un alive
Jews it does not mean to eradicate all
the Jewish people that that's not what
anybody who is speaking in a good aspect
for our movement that is not what we
mean and again are there some radical
people on both side I'm sure there are
we can't control everybody but for for
the most part and for the majority no we
don't want to get rid of Jewish people
no human being who has a heart should
want to get rid of any person both sides
have lost the
war
hello again hello want to
go um well don't know exactly about both
sides but I can tell you about my side
uh I feel that we lost the war the the
day the Kamas came to our people in the
slaughter 1400 of our people and they
raped our women and they beheaded our
babies and
all of that and I was there that day I
was on the beach and we had a party
friends of mine from uh from
college and we parted the whole night
until 6:00 a.m. and then 6:30 the rocket
started followed by boats coming from
the sea and they mounted the shore and
they killed front of me follow of my
friends they killed 40 people including
couples 17-year-old kids they killed
fishermen fathers and son they come to
the Sea every day for the F for the past
40 years and they slaughter them all and
they slaughtered my friend my dear
friend
MO and I don't know how many of you
seeing like we talked about the media
the news and all of that so when it all
happened on October 7th the Kamas really
posted everything on Telegram and I saw
the whole the whole all the holes and
can talk you talk to you about every
single video of it and how they beheaded
people and how they raped our
women and burned babies in the
ovens for me no matter what happens next
we lost this war we lost our brothers we
lost our
friends no no military act
or nothing can bring them
back actually the the main reason why I
think we
lost alongside with that
is our hostages 241 people to was was
hostages some of them were released
right now women and children but there
at least 170 people still in Gaza being
held captives no one speaks about it
people ripping out those posters every
day so when we get so when we see the
world and we know that no one cares for
them for me we lost
yeah I
uh I think when the question came to me
I was thinking of a win lose because
there's there's never going to be a win
right so even if we find the peace we
all want and the
freedom um I have a hard time calling it
a win that we've as you've mentioned so
many innocent people have died children
women Etc so that's the main reason I
came up here you can't classify anything
else about a loss even if it outcomes
are better and things get better we've
all lost it's tragedy and so many
innocent people died um in the last 6 to
8 weeks you know 2 million in GDA have
been displaced from their homes 18,000
have died um 8,000 of them have been
children about 4,000 women this is from
the euromed health monitor um and
generally these These are these um these
numbers that come from GZA end up being
verified by the UN so it's sad and also
as you mentioned the innocent civilians
and children who are taken hostage in uh
on October 7th and none of that is okay
so yeah it's a loss
do you think it's appropriate to be
partying till 6:00 in the morning a few
miles away from an open air prison where
people don't have water except for clean
water is not available to 95% of the
inhabitants electricity is only
available 11 hours of the
day bombardments have been ensuing every
3 to 5 years non-stop do you think it's
appropriate for you to be
partying a couple miles away from such a
situation yes because think it's fair
yeah of course it is because it's not
our fault it's not your fault you know
how much controls the water supply to I
no Israel controls the water supply they
not pip they not shut off the water and
the electricity
and the fuel then who controls it if
they shut it off who controls it
research no no no
no I'm going let you talk I'm going to
let you talk if Israel shut off the
water the fuel and the electricity the
Gaza who controls the water electricity
of fuel you took all the money and to
and who controls them I answer my
question can I answer the question then
how did Israel cut it off is Israel is
not even
stepping cut the water the P controls
the P controls gaza's water situation
okay P for the Palestinian Water
Authority okay they control the water
situation in Gaza Gaza on how did Israel
is Israel has a pipeline that goes into
Gaza it's a very small pipeline it could
gives about 10% of gaza's water gaza's
water's problem actually started long
before even 2005 they have a number of
Aqua fores on their on their Shores one
of their main Aqua Force which is not
enough to sustain the population growth
which has come to be they also have a
lot of other problems with contamin
why because their
contamination no we left them a
perfectly good sewer Grid in 05 great
sewer grid but it was for the population
size that was there right now the
population has grown significantly where
those contamination plants the
wastewater treatment plants can't uh uh
process the amount of water that's
coming in so what happens the Overflow
goes into the ocean which further
degrades the water that's coming in from
the aquafor it's actually a really
situation there's a number of
organiz there's a number of
organizations in Israel that are
actually working on this problem right
now however long-term solutions for
water has to come from diplomatic means
because we need to be able to get the
supplies in and those supplies that are
large enough to be able to sustain
gaza's water to be able to build and
scale to what it actually needs right
now violate the Dual use policy of
things that come in because they are
used for Rockets another hug water is
being used for Rockets the PIP the pipes
are used for Rockets which is a really
really big issue because it means that
it violates the J's policy which means
that you can't bring things in that are
large enough to be able to create those
Terror items this is a very situation
and I think that Gins deserve clean
drinking water and it's a very it's a
very big problem because the internal
structure of the water is not run by we
have a very minor pipeline that goes
into Israel and that's the water that is
controlled that is the water took all
the money because of all all of the
terror that has come out of Gaza has
created these blockades over the years
the blockades have gotten stronger and
stronger because of the terror that has
come out colletive punishment you're
saying the parying I I listen the party
I think it's Collective punishment by
Hamas the the parying that's happening
at 600 a.m. on the beach right next to
it right that's also happening next door
to a place that's being sending
thousands of rockets into Israel every
single day so is it right to be able to
send thousands of rockets into Isel
every single day no no we pulled out of
Gaza the water system in Gaza was set up
for the current population very big
issues with that okay regardless but I
think that more people need to do actual
research on the water situation before
speaking about Israel shutting on or off
we shut off 10% of the water there was
already a water crisis in Gaza the war
now the war has completely EX that
crisis and also not just that but the
water in Gaza is very heavily privatized
so people with money get access to water
there it's so sad so the poor people are
actually even even worse out of luck and
they get charged more for their water
it's a huge problem and it's something
that there are a ton of orgs that are
actually working to try and fix that but
again we need diplomatic solutions to
this and that means we need a government
that we can have diplomatic relations
with which is not Hamas the goal of uh
Israel in this war is to make sure that
the Jewish state will stay alive for me
as long as the Jewish States stay alive
Israel is always winning because the
other side want to eliminate the Jewish
State that's their goal that's the Kamas
goal I'm not saying it's your goal I'm
saying that's the Kamas goal to
eliminate Israel and the Jewish State as
long as they not eliminating and they're
not killing uh or wiping the Jewish
State I think the Jewish State always
winning um and the goal of uh uh the
Jewish state right now it's to wipe off
Hamas not the Palestinian people Hamas
only and once have they succeeded not
yet not yet have they have they killed
more people disproportionately do you
know the ratio of how many Hamas to each
civilian it's the same argument you said
the goal is to H it will get a different
tell you said the goal is to eliminate
Hamas around they said hundreds maybe
100 or or more Hamas members died what
did you say how many thousand how many
thousand pal we had way more than 18,000
no we've killed people died the ratio is
1 to 100 1 to 100 this is the most
capable military in the world you can't
be more accurate your ratio can't be
better than they're hiding hospital so
go on the ground so go on the ground
fight why why should why should you kill
our innocent Civ they're attacking us
and they're hiding behind your people
civilians attack you no hiding by the
way a lot of civilians from Gaza went in
on October 7th because there was the the
pay you got $10,000 plus an apartment
actually a lot of Goen citizens went in
you saw them in plane closing going
through the border and coming in and
kidnapping people that's why some of the
hostages can't be found you guys
people H H 1500 which I have never heard
about more in my life except for the
past month and a half I want to cuz I'm
going to be that that's what I well we
give you facts and then you guys say no
that didn't happen 5,000 people invaded
Israel 1500 of them wereas the rest of
them were civilians from my perspective
the reason why I did not step forward is
because I feel like
Palestinians again from my perspective
have lost more in the recent events
based on numbers and over the last 75
years the fact that also Israel is one
of the strongest militaries in the world
funded by the United States to the tune
of billions of dollars every year from
our
is from our taxpayer money
please okay the amount of money
Palestine gets versus what Israel gets
is not the same amount you can look it
up in American taxes you can see how
much goes to each one money it is not
same about black money Israel probably
gets black money too not like not like
you know what we're not talking about
that I am trying to tell you why I did
not step forward okay you cannot say
that it's equal on both sides you cannot
say that we have suffered the same since
October 7th okay because the numbers are
there I acknowledge that you have lost
friends I want you to acknowledge that
we have lost a lot of people to a a
higher percentage a higher ratio and
whether or not you believe it's
Collateral Damage I believe it is and I
don't feel that it is fair that we say
that our suffering has been the same
since October 7th the suffering is
immense and it's great for both of us
but when you look at the numbers it's
disproportionate and that is why I don't
think that we both sides have lost the
War I believe Israel has the advantage
right now because they have the military
they have the tanks they have the
weapons the people in Gaza literally the
civilians have nothing to defend
themselves with their buildings are
falling on them it's fault they had so
many years in 2006 you know what for
once I would like when I say something
about Palestinian suffering that you
don't turn the blame just on Hamas
because it's fault it's possible to be
both pro-israel and pro
Palestine I'm Pro two State solution so
that's pretty much why I walked up here
I don't think a one state is reasonable
I think two states is much easier to
accomplish it's been something our um
former leaders yaser Arafat Rabin Etc
they've put in so much work into the two
states I just don't see a one state
solution being viable you don't have to
be Pro countries but I'm I'm Pro both
having their own independent land
couldn't agree with you Vibes I actually
uh think in a different way I uh have um
um a problem with the whole state
politics this the whole system thing um
I'm
a I'm a rebel to systems you know and it
doesn't matter what system is it so uh
for me you yeah you can like both sides
you can you can have be Pro uh uh both
sides I believe we can uh uh there there
is a way I don't know if it's in this
world right now we can be friends and we
can uh uh host each other without
talking about a whole state thing you
know so I think friendship doesn't come
from a state thing from a system thing I
think friendship and a peace comes from
wanting just to be a friend with another
person I acknowledge you as a human
being and you deserve to live wherever
you want and I'm okay with that I have
no problem with you living next to me
you know it doesn't matter where you
come from when I think about Pro
Palestinians it's I like I divided to
two sections if you're talking about the
death of innocent people if it's
children women men whatever it is then
I'm agree with you and I'm really I told
you before I really s for innocent
people that are dying but there is the
other part of the pro Palestine thing
and which is pro Hamas or not condemning
Hamas and with that part I can agree
never yeah I feel I mean some people
feel the same way about the netanyahu's
right-wing evil government you know I
feel like you should be able to condemn
both um condemn what the government well
first of all netanyahu's been public
about saying that his um his stance is
is recently there's um I think it was
harit he openly said I'll make sure as
long as I'm in power I'll make sure
there is no Palestinian state if we're
talking about Natan I think we all have
agreements or disagreements I have BR no
I come from um a very very very
right-wing family right we never had
those words in my home I I believe you
and I I never had I never had one person
you compare you can't you can't compare
Nan's government to Hamas which are
terrorists think the world you can't are
you can't do that sorry Hamas are
terrorists who killing and raping and
beheading children and is nothing the
same nothing the same as Nan or the
Israeli government and if you're if
you're comparing the Israeli government
or the Israeli state to Hamas then my
friend you have a serious problem I do
and I think I think many people do many
people what because they both do things
like kill civilians right for political
gain so you could say these ones are
brown and they're D they coming in Crazy
whatever and you could say this one's
just dropping bombs from the sky the end
result is the same you're killing I'm
talking ham I'm talking about
monsters how can you how can you compare
not humans how can you compare monsters
and animals yeah well that's to people
oh so because comp let me be clear these
ones are animals these are not no Hamas
is animals I'm not talking about the
Palestinian I'm talking Hamas okay why
they did in October 7th they are animals
they are monsters animals you know
animals kill to to feed their children
animals killed to feeds to survive they
did it for fun so for me their month the
theity nothing to be negotiated about
brutality the brutality is more on the
lud side so I think that being
pro-israel and being a Zionist is
inherently actually being quite Pro
Palestinian I believe that I have the
right to self-determination as a Jew in
my homeland and therefore I believe that
Palestinians also have that same right
and I think that the most pro-israel
thing you can do is want to live in
peace it's one of the biggest tenants of
being in Israel Jews are hated
everywhere around the world just for
being Jewish and there's literally one
place in the world where you just step
into and for a second you are not hated
for a second you're some random Danish
person who never had to grow up with a
bunch of people hating them for their
peoplehood for some reason that is just
uh uh something that people can't really
acknowledge and they don't seem to be
able to validate or accept but I
personally think that the biggest part
of being a Zionist is wanting to live in
peace it's coming in there peacefully
it's trying to negotiate it's trying to
come in with diplomacy that's the whole
tenant of Zionism and to me that's the
biggest pro-israel thing you can do and
that's what I see when I'm in Israel and
that's what I see from all of the Jews
that are around me 24/7 I'm So Pro
Palestine I'm so pro-israel and I'm
really just prum all
around the overwhelming majority of
Jewish people just want to be able to
have a a a Homeland where they can live
in peace with their neighbors period no
one would like to see a free Palestine
more than Jewish people because it would
mean they wouldn't be fighting anymore I
I dream of that scenario where there are
Israelis living in peace and
Palestinians living in peace and
everybody's just going about their
business and we're sharing the sandbox
and getting along
nicely the way that I see it um the way
that Palestinians are under occupation
right now they're under occupation by
Israel so I cannot see myself being
pro-israel in the way that it is right
now with the government that it has and
I personally am a one-state person um I
hope everybody here knows this but pre-
1948 Jews Christians and Muslims all
lived in the land together not
peacefully and peacefully I peacefully
no look into Jerusalem yeah pre can you
please stop interrupting me when I'm
speaking you got to speak thousand of
Jewish people died 1913 look into
Jerusalem so for me that's why I say if
someone in this moment comes to me and
says I'm pro-israel and I'm Pro
Palestine it makes me feel like it's
just a very neutral stance not wanting
to take either side for me as long as
Palestinians are under occupation and
don't have freedom of movement the
Israel that exists right now is not one
that I personally can support I'm not
saying this about the people I'm not
saying I want to get rid of the Jews or
the Israelis look all of us here are
younger than the state of Israel we did
not create this so I don't think that we
can point fingers at each other and not
see that we don't have the stakes that
the leaders and those that came before
them did when when they created this
problem when Palestinians have their
basic human rights and are treated
equally under the law we can call the
state whatever you want to call it and
at that point I would be happy to call
you all my friends and my neighbors and
there would be no problem it seems that
everybody here has the same idea for the
future and I think that is the thing
that we should be focusing
on reason I didn't step forward um is
quite similar because when I hear the
word Israel I don't think the tribes of
Israel I think the state of Israel and
the state of Israel the foundation that
it's built upon is a racist Ideology Now
did it always start like that I don't
think so I think there was some racism
in there but I do agree in reading the
works of hadam um you know even even
Herzel um there was some desire to do do
our own thing and let them do their own
thing I Am pro Palestine and Pro Jewish
people and pro an eventual states that
we can call it
Jerusalem do you know where kbut the
originate from it originates from blocks
of land and communities that were
intentionally purchased in one
continuous plot so that it can exclude
anyone besides the Jewish people and I
don't even want to say the jewi Jewish
people the zist people so until we get
rid of these ideologies that sought to
create division then we cannot be Pro
two things that are diametrically
opposed we can be
Pro Jerusalem pre-1914 which was a
beautiful bustling vibrant city with the
streets filled with vendors making
delicious streets you smell the scent of
fresh bread as you walk through there
was Muslims Christians Jews coexisting
in Perfect Harmony Perfect Harmony it
was after the a mass migration started
to happen the first elah the second elah
the third El
that's when tensions arose we were
living together no problem my friend me
and you a thousand years ago we would
have been
Brothers but there was a there was an
ideology that wanted an exclusionary
xenophobic ideology a colonial one from
Europe that was imported into our land
and that one we cannot coexist with CU
it does not consider us as people it can
coexist with it's by Nature exclusionary
it's not that I'm not pro-israeli people
or Pro Jewish people people it is
against the ideology of how the state of
uh Israel was created and the racism
behind that do you understand that
saying you're pro-jewish people but
you're against the idea of them having
self-determination over themselves in a
piece of their Homeland to a Jew that
sounds very anti-jewish that's not what
I heard her say I heard her say she's
against the way Israel came about she
didn't say she's against Jewish people
having their own
Homeland that that is what those three
people agree to I never said
that right for selfdetermination I said
if it is contingent on the fact of
excluding the other side if you wanted
to have a state hey let's have a Jewish
State that's welcome to everybody
perfect no it's not no it's not that's
not what they thought that's not what
they that's why they bought the land
that's why they bought the lands
inous that's why they bought the land
second class citizenship that's why they
bought the land in contiguous plots
that's why they only employed jewi
people commanders in the army they said
they wanted to till the land by their
own hands so they can
earn like i' really like to answer this
one okay so imperialism right
imperialism is the idea of coming in and
imposing your religion and your language
and everything on a group of people
right that's what was coming from Europe
Israel did not want to do that Zionism
started to be the anti-imperialism we
wanted to come in and we wanted to
diplomatically figure out a solution to
be able to both live there and the
Diplomatic solution was not an ethnos of
Jews it was a majority Jewish state that
was the offer but it was 45% Arab and
not to mention that by the way but we're
forgetting about a whole bunch of other
people who have ancestral ties to the
land the dreim the BNS I mean it's not
just Jews and Muslims and Arabs and
Christians so many but they're all
welcome in Israel and in Israel the Arab
Israelis that live there have 100% are
second class citizens they are not
allowed the same education they are not
afforded
not been there my
friend you want the statis how do you
know that my friend we live there I live
in the North I live alongside with Arab
people only Arabs only Arabs running a
hospital there is no way going to the
not receive the same gr they don't
receive the same grants from the
government the teachers are not allowed
the teachers are not allowed to have
their own curriculum they don't even
have to serve in the IDF they examp when
a lot of speaking of the IDF a lot of
the mil a lot of the qualifications to
qualify for government support when I
Ser B on serving in the SP years which
excludes Arabs being in the Army okay
and then when I finish I want to go to
the university so I need to have X my
grade in the SAT let's say it's X okay
so the Arab people in Israel those say
are discriminated need to get half X as
M grade to get into the universities
although they didn't serve three years
in the Army so affir discrimination this
way they're becoming doctors affirmative
action affirmative action is given to
people who are tell this minority and
who are oppressed minority not oppressed
minority the whole majority of doctors
in Israel and nurses are people most of
the doctor in two things can be true at
the same time cour that's true two
things can be true at the same time that
could be true it also can be true in
order to qualify for certain discri
because you're not from there you don't
know it
I and also a underlying systematic
discrimination it's
not I protested Muslim Christians I was
there in t multiple protests exactly
Jews Ethiopian Jews how are they treated
we've made a lot we've Made A lot's a
difference uh societal racism which
exists in every country and certainly
Israel is no
exception and sort of this sort of
systematic like they can't live there
and they're not allowed or whatever the
the proposition was here yeah there is
definitely discrimination and racism in
Israel as there is in America as there
is everywhere else for sure but it's
that is a very different thing that
we're talking about no it's the same
thing because I just want to touch on
the fact that you're saying that Israeli
Arabs are being treated uh
fairly maybe some maybe let's say five
out of 10 right no all of
them that is not true but legally
speaking they have all the same Supreme
Court Justice put the
isra byw
there will there ever be a Palestinian
president of Israel difference president
of Palestine there ever be Arab will
there ever could honestly if Arabs and
Israel are equ do you truly believe tell
me genuinely from the bottom of your
heart Arab Israeli that has Palestinian
interests in mind the people the
interest of his people in mind can ever
be president of
Israel you know the last government
there is an party who was in the
Coalition was in the government lasted
for what like asking would America ever
have a black
president I empathize with people on the
other
side
I will say that I learned a lot from
this round table and I mean while I have
a lot of Jewish friends I haven't met
many people who were also Israeli who
had lived there who
served and you know not to say that I
did not have empathy I've always been
empathetic you know as an activist as
someone who's a public figure in
Washington DC I constantly get hateful
DMS from people that will say things
like do you like condemn the murder of
innocent Israelis and I'm like the fact
that someone is asking me that means
that they see me as somebody just
because I'm Palestinian as someone who
doesn't have a heart that doesn't care
about innocent lives and this is
something that I I get constantly and it
it's exhausting having to always defend
not only myself as a Palestinian but the
fact that obviously I don't want anyone
to die and I don't want anyone to hurt
and I don't think that anyone should be
killed for who they are whether it's
based on their religion or their country
of origin all of us were born into this
you know you were born on one side I was
born on the other we have our own lived
experiences you know some of us have
lived there many of us have visited
there and on both sides I think that we
can recognize that at the end of it and
at the very basis of this entire day and
this
conversation is that we're really just
human beings that care about our
identities we're very passionate about
it you know we're you know we're willing
to fight for who we are and and that's
our Middle Ground like whether or not we
agreed on a lot of things which we
definitely did not I think that the the
fact that we have so much passion just
shows how much we actually care and how
much we actually can relate to each
other and resonate with what the other
is going through I empathize um with the
other side uh because as she said I'm a
human being and and I I I I love humans
I love being a human being I love the
interaction with human beings um and at
the end of the day like when you said
that people message you and say oh well
do what about uh the Israeli IES that
die and you saying that they paint you
into this person that's an evil person
for being Palestinian we are
Palestinians that doesn't mean that
we're terrorists I'm tired of being
called a terrorist I'm tired of being
called a Hamas lover I we are
humanitarians is there good and bad on
both sides yes but immediately the
spotlight goes straight to us oh well
you're Palestinian so you must be a
terrorist and you don't empathize with
the other if you if you're human you
empathize with any law of Life across
the globe no matter what you
are that's it what what's so interesting
again at so much of what you said it's
like the exact same words come out of
our mouth so like I get people being
like well because I'm standing by Israel
P I want all Palestinians to die and I
have no empathy for any poor children or
anything like that so I get exactly what
you're going through on the other side
and so what this conversation has done
for me is to and what I sort of hoped it
would do is to get to hear from you and
to what I sort of expected which is what
it was is that we have very similar
experiences through totally different
lenses and totally different specifics
but we're experiencing a lot of the same
things and I think without empathy it's
over I mean there's no point to anything
if we're not going to try to reach each
other as human beings and see each other
as human beings we're effed to to use
your word
yeah I'd love to also answer the prompt
a bit Jonah is so nicely put and also so
nicely put I think that for me my
experience throughout my life I've
always been in um situations where I'm
like the only Jew and so frequently I
get a lot of ridiculous questions like
where are your horns or I was raised to
think that you were the cause of all my
problems and I grew up in America I'm
not even exaggerating um and I've had to
like you know be a representative of the
Jewish people for so many years and I'm
very acutely aware of the fact that
there's not that many of of us so many
people have never met a Jew or someone
who's lived in Israel 75% of the world
has never met a Jew and I'm not even
surprised I've met a whole chunk of them
you know what you mean and it's really
dehumanizing when so often I'm faced
with like legitimate stereotypes that I
can't even believe people think are real
and yet they do and I think that
probably a similar experience happens on
your guys' end where you feel
dehumanized to the point where like
people never actually hear your stories
or like listen to you or have ever even
met like a Palestinian that lives in
Palestine to be able to understand that
and I think so much of this conversation
like we were speaking about before is
overrun by a bunch of random white
people who have nothing to do with this
at all and like there's so much
dehumanization that comes from that
experience of all these people kind of
like arguing against you or for you and
not even understanding you at all and I
think that my biggest objective coming
here today was like to just humanize
both of us our experiences are so the
same our food is literally the same you
know this is like we're just two sides
of the same coin 100% agreed that we are
the Same by Nature as human beings
empathy is the ability to feel what
another human being feels right so of
course I think we all have empathy by
Nature unless we're Psychopaths or
sociopaths to which they have that
turned off right and some of those
people are the ones running this show
right unfortunately which is why it
seems like there is no empathy but I
think every one of you guys from what I
felt have empathy
and I hope you feel that I have empathy
too I hope you feel that I have deep
pain I hope you feel that I've I'm from
a people that's been deeply
oppressed I hope you can feel that
definitely and my ideal solution would
be a place where everyone has empathy
for one another and it is void of those
sociopaths that don't regard the other
this as the same as they are so when I
asked does Palestine have the right to
defend itself there shouldn't be from
who what when no if a does a human being
from Palestine do I have the right to
defend myself
yeah then we can start here and move
towards a solution I think you let
certain people off too easy I think
there are people who are not sociopaths
who don't tap into that empathy because
I think it takes intention to be
empathetic and I think we sometimes take
that for granted that that we're like oh
I'm I'm a human I'm going to be empath
but and it's not enough to just sort of
intellectually acknowledge something
it's as you said as you defin it you
need to feel it or it's not going to get
through to you and I think a lot of
people probably the majority of people
don't take the time to actually
internalize that and feel it they go
yeah no no I get it I feel I feel really
bad for them and then we've moved on
because I've I've checked the empathy
box you have to but you have to feel it
and not everybody does that and it's
really you have to take the time to to
take that step yeah that was fantastic
Jonah I stage left yeah I guess
Salam
day are you hugger Shaker hug shake you
are thank you for great to meet you and
keep I'll
try
app
yes than it's okay I know I know you
you've got a lot of pain yeah sorry no
i
f man you were born Jewish you would
have been the first thing I everything
happened on October
7ali it's going to be really sad
Devastation is going to be felt
everywhere you know so
sorry